hey everyone welcome back to another
workout
i have a special guest with me today
hani madhu who is a singer and also a
fitness instructor
so she's going to be doing the workout
together with us
you up for it yeah today's workout is
going to be a
total body workout it's going to work on
your strength
your power as well as your endurance all
right
so it's going to be 40 seconds of work
and 20 seconds of
active recovery so let's get our body
warmed up
and let's do this together
let's start with an easy warm-up just to
get our engine moving okay
so the first will be leg curls so step
side to side
curl left leg try to get your heels
to touch your butt okay and really open
up your arms
feel the stretch on your chest as well
as
your back muscles so nice and easy
allowing the blood to flow in our body
and also to warm up
all the major muscles good two more
and let's get into some squats okay
so toes pointer forward let's go squat
with a side leg wrist down
up down and up so what i'm going to do
is push your arms back and feel the
stretch
and work on your triceps as well so
try to go lower okay good push your butt
back
chest up and down
very good so remember to always keep
your chest up
back flat do not hunch forward
give me two more one more
and all right let's get into a high
plank okay
and let's do the world's greatest
stretch
okay so step your leg left leg forward
and
open up reach your left arm up
back down into a high plank and change
side
so right leg forward right arm up and
change
and really feel the stretch on your
glutes your hip flexor and also
your back good so look up step back
down give me
two more on each side okay back high
plank
back down one more
last one left back down
and let's slowly inch back up
into a standing position all right good
so the first circuit will be focusing on
your lower body there will be lots of
squats and also lunges
we're gonna start easy okay and as we
progress
we're going to bring the energy up into
some plier movements
are we ready yeah okay so the first
workout is going to be
a squat ready let's go remember stand
shoulder width apart
toes pointer forward push your butt back
40 seconds
of squats down and up
again push your arms back and bring them
forward
as you squat down keep going
nice push it back
feel the work on your thighs your glutes
and that's where you should feel the
burn
last 10 more seconds keep going
remember to keep your knees soft okay do
not lock your knees
right at the top one more and stay
down pulse 20 seconds
okay stay low and just pulse
yep that burn right there that's what we
want
keep going pause it nice
push it last five seconds keep going
two one okay stand up
let's face this way okay let's get into
a reverse lunge
with your left knee up down reverse
lunge
up down and up so we are working on one
leg
at a time if you can try to drive
your left knee up as high as you can
good and if you're losing your balance
find one focal point okay push up
brace your core back straight
and drive your left knee as high up as
you can good keep going
one more and again i want you to stay
low
and pause 20 seconds of
active recovery more like torture
keep going so you should really feel the
burn on your right thighs
and glute keep going
feel more and we want to switch side
okay step back ready let's go right leg
back
right knee up down up
down and up there's always one leg
where it's harder to balance isn't it
keep going
try to bring your knee as close to the
floor as possible
up and down and remember to breathe
throughout the workout do not hold your
breath
breathe in and breathe out as you come
up
in and out good keep going
last two more and stay low let's go
ready pause good
ah feel the burn left
glute right here left side okay
strong legs nice keep going
breathe okay five more seconds that's it
stay with me and up all right
are you okay now
let's get into sumo squat okay
step wide with your toes pointed out all
right i just wanted to
push your butt back and come back up
this is going to work
on your inner thighs and your outer
glutes
down and up good down enough
and remember to point your toes out push
your knees
out as well okay
good working on your inner thighs
do you feel the stretch on the inner
thighs good keep going
one more and now stay low pulse
i told you there will be lots of pulses
and also isometric holes in this workout
ah feel the burn come on keep going
10 seconds
and stay with me three two
one okay back up all right
one final workout okay so stand
with your toes pointer forward let's get
into curtsy lunge
so right leg cross over step back
left leg cross and step back ready let's
do it together
right step left and step
remember you want to cross over
and feel the work on your outer glutes
okay
good and balanced yeah step
down and up and the final 20 seconds
let's add in a little bit of plyo
movement
skaters okay step back and step
ready let's go skateless try to reach
good left and right reach
keep going
keep going you're gonna get a short
break
right after this and rest okay
[Music]
okay are we ready let's continue on
the second round okay squat instead of
squats
let's do squat jumps all right ready
let's go 30 seconds
push it up up good
same workout but let's bring the heat up
let's add in plier movements point your
toes
down up push it back
if this is too tough stay in a squat
position okay
find your pace that's two more
one two stand up let's get down
into squat pulses 20 seconds
stay with me good
we can feel your burn okay we can feel
your pain
do not stop right now if you need to
come up
count to three counts one two three get
back down
and pass all right good
ah reverse lunges with hops okay
take a short break breathe catch your
breath
let's work on one leg at a time right
leg forward left leg back okay
same thing let's add in a small hop take
a step back
hop okay very small hop
let's go again if this is too
challenging
just maintain the first
reverse lunges without any hop
keep going
that's one more okay are you ready
let's go lunge pulses okay let's go down
up pulse
small pulses again if this is too much
come back up count to three one two
three
get back down all right i want you to
finish the workout
with me good shake it out
all right we have two legs so now
let's move on to the left side honey you
got this okay
oh yeah okay right leg back
left leg forward down hop
down and hop good don't rush
through the workout take it at your own
pace listen to
your own body right you're not in
competition
with someone else it's your own progress
this is your journey let's keep going
two more one more
ready lunge back let's go pulse
two three four five come back up
let's do five pulses one two
three four five back up good
one two three four
five back up and one okay
ah let's work on the inner thighs
and the outer glutes if you need to take
a short break
wipe your sweat drink some water feel
free to do so
okay crease cross squats all right
so what i'm going to do is point your
toes out give me three pulses
cross three process and cross
are we ready let's go down one two
three crisscross one two three
cross good
almost there down two
three okay passes let's go down
push it back let's do five times and
let's come back up
down again one two three four
five back up one two
three four five up last one
one two three four five
okay curtsy lunch okay
alternating curtsy lunch so stand with
your toes
pointed forward bring your left leg back
cross over
okay together let's go last
final workout and you will get a one
minute break good you're almost there
all right only 40 seconds left you got
this
cross over making sure that your body
is always pointed forward keep going
cross your legs one more on each side
and let's get into skaters let's go
left and right left and right
good there you go
10 seconds
breathe out pace your breathing last
five seconds
and very very
well done that is the end
of the first circuit focusing on your
lower body
take a shot one minute break wipe your
sweat if you need to
keep yourself hydrated and we want to
focus on
your upper body and call for the second
circuit
high five halfway through
[Music]
honey is still with us okay so it is not
too bad
let's finish this workout together the
second circuit will be focusing on your
upper body
as well as your core if you have a mat
grab a mat
alright so let's start with the first
workout which will be a push-up with
rotation for a regressed version you can
do the push-up on your knees
just like what honey is doing okay let's
go push up
rotate left arm up back down
one push-up and back up
try to get your chest as close to the
floor
as possible
[Music]
and for the 20 seconds of active
recovery
is going to be an isometric hold so it's
going to really
challenge your upper body strength
and just to activate the muscles even
more
keep going give me
two more push-ups okay
okay take it at your own pace up
and now push up and hold stay low
and hold it for 20 seconds
i'm feeling the burn okay stay low and
get your car
do not dip your hips do not pike your
butt up
stay with me five more seconds pull it
and just relax okay
mountain climber alright so get up onto
a plank position
i'm going to bring your right knee
towards your elbow
and alternate with your left knee okay
again if you need to take a short break
in between
feel free to do so right knee
nice and controlled and for the last
10 seconds we want to speed it up
that's two more seconds are we ready
honey let's speed it up ready let's go
speed climber only 10 seconds
three two one okay hold it
stay in this high plank position and
just hold this pose
brace a core if your body is shaking
that is absolutely fine that means
you're engaging
every part of the muscles in your body
okay
hold it three more seconds
now okay let's sit on our butt
crab toe touch all right point your toes
forward
point your fingers forward lift your
butt up
okay what i'm going to do is alternate
and try to reach
your left hand to your right toe
okay so find that balance
lift your butt up push it it's all about
core engagement right here
good nice keep going reach
if you can't tap then just try to reach
your ankle good keep going
and now reverse plank hold so on your
heels
and lift your glutes up and just hold it
high hips okay do not dip up
point keep going
and back down back
into a plank let's go for plank jacks
all right for the regrets version do
follow honey
ready let's go out and in
or you can take one foot out
at a time and just breathe
nice halfway there very good
you're gonna love the 20 seconds plank
hold
keep going strong shoulders strong core
three two one okay let's get into a
plank
and just hold it for 20 seconds
think of someone else okay think of a
nice holiday
i wish i was on a holiday right now
that's four three two
one okay back onto
your butt knee tucks all right
so point your toes forward
fingers pointed forward let's go drive
your knee in
out in and out
good we're not rushing through this
workout
i want you to feel your lower abs
working and the entire core as well
good
breathe and for the final 10 seconds
we're just going to point your toes and
hold one more
okay toes pointed if you want to drop
onto your elbows
and just hold whoa feel that burn
everything is shaking hold it last 10
seconds
and we will we will get a 30 seconds
break
suck your belly in come on guys hold it
two
one ah what a bird
okay oh good news
we're repeating the entire circuit once
more okay
yes good news you know the workouts
give me your best effort and let's
finish the remaining
five minutes all right are we ready
push up with rotation okay
five seconds left let's get into a high
and let's go push up left
arm up good push
remember your goal is to try to get your
chest
as close to the ground as possible
rotate
as you rotate you want to make sure to
keep
your hips lifted alright so do not
dip your hip rotate
if you have a partner doing this workout
with you you want to cheer her on
come on honey keep going one more
and it's going to be a high plank hold
alright good for a firmer base what you
can do
is to spread your fingers apart okay
and just breathe
strong core
and just drop onto your knees
take a short stretch
and we want to get straight into
mountain climbers let's go
high plank 30 seconds let's go right
knee
left knee alternating good
okay take it at your own pace if you
feel that
you need to drop onto your knees feel
free to do so for two seconds
come back up and continue alright let's
go speed climbers
breathe
and let's just get into a plank position
low plank hold it
oh my gosh i can feel every inch of my
muscles
burning right now keep going
and back down okay onto
your butt okay
let's go crab toe touch all right toast
pointer forward
fingers pointer forward let's get up
make sure you have your feet firmly
planted on the ground let's go
opposite side
keep going remember to lift
your butt as high as you can
right hand to left toes
reach good
this is also going to work on your
coordination and mobility
let's go reverse plank hole so stay on
your heels
lift your hips up point your fingers
forward
and if you want to just stare
up at the ceiling
and just breathe
and straight into playing jacks alright
final two exercises hi plank
ready let's do this together out and in
good
keep going making sure that your back is
flat
throughout the entire movement
last 10 seconds give me five more
two three four five
stay ready hold
20 seconds this is your final
plank workout we have one more minute
left
after this hold it
feel the burn on your shoulders your
core
and down okay one final workout okay
knee tucks just like when is this
workout going to finish
i bet you're thinking the same thing at
home as well okay
finger pointer forward legs up let's go
drive your knee in towards your chest
and back
out if this is too difficult what you
can do is do
alternate knee tucks okay so rest one
heel
back up rest it and rest
if not let's go for the full version
on an in out and in
all right that's one more and now
let's drop onto our elbows are you ready
for this final hole
let's go heels off the floor
suck your belly in feel that pain feel
that shake
breathe let's count five
four three two
one
okay
i love honey she's got lots of attitude
and you can tell
the intensity of the workout through
her expression judy come over here
so well done for those of you at home
who have completed this workout let us
know in the comments below
leave us an ig message how this workout
went
and if you want to see more of honey do
let us know as well okay
and perhaps she might lead the next
session
in the next workout yeah okay
let's do a three minute cooldown a
really quick cooldown
all right let's just get into
a plank position more planks
don't worry it's going to be a cool down
let's get into a plank
push your butt back into a downward
facing dog
i want you to just take your time we're
not rushing to go anywhere
let's bring our heart rate down and
really feel the stretch
on your hamstrings your back muscles
and also your lower back so really push
your palms into the floor
and try to get your heels to the floor
okay and now just lower yourself down
into
a cobra palms by your chest
push yourself up and remember do not
sink
into your shoulders okay push away from
your shoulders
and just look up
and breathe
fold it for another five pounds
you'll be glad you completed this
workout and now
push your butt back into a child's pose
all right again if you can try to get
your butt to touch your heels
and just lengthen your arms
and feel your heart rate back down
and slowly push yourself back up
let's just stay on our knees let's just
take
three deep breaths okay we ready i want
to hear a really loud sigh okay
let's breathe in breathe in really loud
sigh
all the bad energy let's go okay
two more times breathe in stretch up
link your fingers stretch
ready one two three one more time
deep breath in stretch hold it
and go
well done high five high five yes
that is the end of a total body workout
i love this workout combination
thank you for killing me today
challenges your strength
and also really your endurance so if you
enjoy this workout
do give this workout a thumbs up let us
know in the comments below and we will
see you next time
see ya all the best